you're tall were you always tall oh yes
I've been so tall my whole life I mean
that interesting because when we when
women say that they're they're not as
thrilled about it guys I think a lot of
guys like being told oh god it was so I
mean I've always like not know I've
always just been everything grew to like
everything grew too much you know you
don't have to go like that's a choice
you're making people look at me stop
staring when I was younger I like didn't
know how to use my limbs they were so
long yeah I was so tall I was like I was
like when I was 12 I think I was I was
five seven and know by the time I was I
was five nine
but by the time I was like 16 Wow I just
didn't know like what to do I was so
tall and little it happened tall and
little I'm just like I've seen enough
meat on my yeah like stretched out it
doesn't it looked like Gumby yeah I had
so awkward
I grow embarrassed I think I grew I
threw something like 14 inches like in a
year like that's a lie it was well it
was sorry I didn't say where
no I did I think I drew it please it was
horrifying what I just did I apologize